zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
ist das der durchbruch auf den alle
gewartet haben ist bnt 162 b2 aus mainz
die rettung im kampf gegen korona ein
impfstoff der firma piontek zusammen mit
dem us konzern pfizer die wirksamkeit
liegen nach angaben der firma bei 90% es
gebe so gut wie keine nebenwirkungen
nächste woche soll die zulassung
beantragt werden
wie viel anlass zur hoffnung gibt dass
und wenn der impfstoff dann tatsächlich
da ist und zugelassen ist wer bekommt
ihn dann als erstes darüber möchten wir
heute abend sprechen
wir freuen uns auf ihre und eure fragen
wie immer in die kommentare oder wenn
ihr und sie die zdf- heute- app nutzt
dann bitte diese adresse nutzen
wir sprechen darüber heute abend mit der
virologe professor ulrike protzer von
der tu in münchen
schönen guten abend frau professor
protzer grüße sie als sie diese
nachricht heute gehört haben wie haben
sie reagiert erst mal schon erstaunt
aber auch erfreut weil das ergebnis
schon sehr positiv klingt das sind jetzt
natürlich erst mal nur muss man sagen
pressemitteilungen da gibt es noch keine
publizierten daten die man sich
anschauen kann und überprüfen kann aber
das ganze klingt schon mal sehr
vielversprechend wir gehen gleich
nochmal ins detail aber ich möchte gerne
diese stimmung die sich auch über den
tag hinweg noch ein bisschen aufgebaut
hat auch quer durch die politik durch
die wissenschaft auch nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in den usa
da möchte ich gerne noch mal drauf
eingehen der chef von pfizer hat gesagt
heute ist ein ganz besonderer tag für
die wissenschaft und die menschheit
würden sie diese euphorie trotz der
gerade von ihnen schon gemachten
einschränkungen können sie die teilen
also ich glaube es ist ein ganz
wichtiger tag weil wir das erste mal
erfahren haben dass einander der
impfstoffe die in der entwicklung sind
wirklich auch in einer kontrollierten
studie eine wirksamkeit zeigt und das
ist ja das auf was wir irgendwie alle
gehofft haben und er scheint gut
verträglich zu sein zumindest nach allem
was man bisher gehört hat auch das ist
das worauf wir alle gehofft haben dann
schauen wir uns gemeinsam noch mal an um
was für einen impfstoff es sich handelt
was da entwickelt wurde was er kann und
was wir bisher darüber wissen die
hoffnung auf einen wirksamen impfstoff
gegen korona wächst bisher seien die
testergebnisse vielversprechend heißt es
im mainzer unternehmen bei montech sogar
besser als erwartet man kann das
zusammenpassen das ergebnis dass der
impfstoff nach der zwischenauswertung in
der lage ist damit über 30 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit einer infektion zu
verhindern
und so wirkt der sogenannte m rna
impfstoff über ein boten molekül werden
genetische informationen des corona
virus in den menschlichen körper
gebracht der körper stellt damit virus
proteine her gegen die das immunsystem
abwehrstoffe bildet der impfschutz
beginnt in der entscheidenden phase 3
der klinischen tests wurden seit ende
juli mehr als 43.000 probanden weltweit
geimpft
aber wir haben ja eine sehr große gruppe
die geimpft wurde und es traten keine
wesentlichen schwerwiegende
nebenwirkungen auf insofern macht das
durchaus hoffnung die eu hat bereits
mehrere hundert millionen dosen
vorbestellt hohe erwartungen also auch
bei der bundesregierung das war ja bis
hierhin unsicher ob es überhaupt einen
impfstoff geben kann
der tatsächlich wirkt der tatsächliche
infektionsgeschehen reduzierten
infektionen vermeiden hilft und danach
sieht es stand heute aus und das ist
ermutigend 1,4 milliarden dosen will
biontech bis ende nächsten jahres
herstellen und hofft nun auf eine
schnelle zulassung
ob das dieses jahr erfolgt dass das
würde ich nicht ausschließen dass kann
sagen dass es dieses jahr erfolgen kann
es kann aber auch sein dass es anfang
nächsten jahres die ergebnisse von heute
könnten diesen prozess beschleunigen
frau professor prozent ich würde gerne
erstmal bei derart dieses impfstoffs
bleiben
man kennt lebend impfstoffe man kennt so
eben stoffe um das laienhaft
auszudrücken und jetzt gibt es diese art
von impfstoff können sie das zunächst
mal erklären und einordnen
also bisher hat man immer entweder ein
virus an züchten müssen und dann
abgetötet oder man hat es absprechen
müssen bevor man es als im klerus
verwenden konnte oder man hat proteine
das virus oder des erregers gegen dem
man schützen wollte
in ja mit biotechnologischen methoden
hergestellt
das ist alles was was auch jetzt in der
impfstoffentwicklung in der prüfung ist
aber was nicht ganz so schnell machbar
ist und was schon aufwendiger ist als
das was wir jetzt hier haben nämlich 1
rna basierter impfstoff
die arena ist ja ja der botenstoff in
einer zelle um proteine eiweiße
herzustellen das heißt in dem fall ist
es so dass man das eiweiß nicht mehr
außerhalb des körpers herstellt und dann
spritzt sondern man gibt sozusagen die
rna die dann in der zelle die zelle dazu
anregt das eiweiß herzustellen und die
immunantwort auszulösen
das ist der trick des ganzen das ist
nicht gab informationen wie dna die
jetzt in unser genom integrieren kann so
dass man da also keine
sicherheitsbedenken hat sondern das ist
eine ein botenstoff den eine zelle
verwendet um eben eiweiße zu kodieren
der eben und das ist der große vorteil
nicht in das genom integrieren kann der
relativ kurzlebig ist in der zelle und
damit dann auch wieder kaputt geht
ich möchte eine frage von michael adler
auf youtube aufgreifen der fragt wird
der impfstoff nur den verlauf der
krankheit mildern oder auch die
ausbreitung vom virus stoppen
wobei da muss man das anders sehen ist
jaja wird entschuldigung die der
impfstoff kann ja verschiedene dinge tun
er kann einmal denjenigen der geimpft
ist davor schützen dass er sich
infiziert und das ist das was jetzt hier
geprüft wurde und letztendlich
offensichtlich gezeigt wurde
er kann aber auch die ausbreitung des
virus verhindern oder davor schützen
dass man schwerer krank wird oder stirbt
ob der impfstoff das kann das ist
letztendlich noch nicht gezeigt
es ist immer noch möglich dass er zwar
denjenigen schützt der geimpftes aber
dass derjenige trotzdem vielleicht noch
kurzfristig zumindest des virus
weitergeben kann
also es ist nicht bewiesen dass das dass
der impfstoff wirklich die ausbreitung
des virus auch zu 100 prozent hält man
nimmt es schon an aber das ist halt
nicht gezeigt und um zu zeigen dass
jetzt wirklich auch schwere verläufe und
vielleicht sogar die todesfolge
vermindert dazu muss man einfach noch
viel größere studien machen bisher
das ist schon eine große studie haben
wir über 40.000 ich glaube 44.000
menschen sind jetzt in diese studie
eingeschlossen aber das reicht nicht um
zu zeigen dass die schweren verläufe
wirklich runter gehen und auch die
todesfolgen darunter gehen dazu müsste
man ja bis zu einer million oder sogar
mehreren millionen menschen impfen und
das ist in der klinischen studien
natürlich nicht machbar
das heißt dass wir jetzt wissen ist
derjenige der sich impfen lässt ist mit
einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit zumindest
vor der infektion geschützt
nun erreichen uns ziemlich viele fragen
zum zulassungsverfahren und auch zur
beschleunigten geschwindigkeit der
entwicklung dieses impfstoffs und bevor
wir dann die tiefe gehen würde ich mir
gerne gemeinsam angucken welche drei
testphasen in so einer
impfstoffentwicklung durchlaufen werden
müssen bevor ein impfstoff zugelassen
wird muss er getestet werden und zwar
für gewöhnlich in drei phasen in phase 1
wird er weniger als 100 freiwilligen
verabreicht gesunden menschen um die
verträglichkeit zu testen
in phase zwei dann mehreren hundert
menschen darunter auch corona erkrankten
um zu sehen wie das immunsystem reagiert
entscheidend phase 3
tausende bekommen den möglichen
impfstoff damit wird sichergestellt dass
keine massiven neben
auftreten und dass er tatsächlich wirkt
uns erreicht auf youtube die frage von
roland kaiser von dem ich mutmaße dass
es nicht in weiß roland kaiser ist die
frage warum kommt der impfstoff so
schnell und andere brauchen jahre und
müssen jahre lang getestet werden vor
dem hintergrund dieser gerade drei
gezeigten testphasen können sie diese
frage beantworten also das man
normalerweise macht ist man macht eine
phase 1 dann schaut man die ergebnisse
an dann produziert man neu macht eine
phase 2 wartet die ergebnisse ab
produziert wieder neu und fängt mit
einer phase 3 an
und dass man hier gemacht hat um das
ganze zu beschleunigen ist dass man im
vorrat schon mal impfstoff produziert
hat mit beginn der phase 1 so dass er
auf jeden fall durch reicht bis in die
phase 2 rein und dann schon mal vor
produziert hat für die phase 3
das heißt man ist ein herstellungs-
risiko letztendlich ein finanzielles
risiko eingegangen indem man
impfstoffdosen auf vorrat produziert hat
obwohl man gar nicht wusste sind die
ergebnisse der phase eins oder zwei
wirklich so gut dass man in eine phase
drei gehen würde
und auch da hat muss man jetzt sehr
gegangen während der phase 3 und hat
schon mal angefangen impfstoffe zu
produzieren später für die klinik wenn
das ganze dann zugelassen wird das ist
ein teil der beschleunigung der zweite
teil der beschleunigung ist wir hatten
vorher gesagt man braucht doch 44.000
menschen studienteilnehmer in einer
solchen studie
wenn ich das jetzt nur im zwei drei der
vier zentren mache dann dauert das
natürlich sehr lange bis die diese
44.000 probanden rekrutiert haben
geimpft haben untersucht haben um das zu
beschleunigen hat man jetzt einfach sehr
viele studienzentren ausgewählt und die
haben alle parallel gearbeitet und wenn
man dann sehr viele zentren hat dann ist
der zeitraum natürlich kürzer dem man
braucht damit die gesamtzahl erreicht
wird und man versucht das ist der letzte
punkt dann auch in regionen zu gehen in
denen schon ein heftiges
infektionsgeschehen stattfindet warum
man will hier an einer phase 3 auch die
wirksamkeit
zeigen und die kann man natürlich nur
zeigen wenn sich eine gewisse anzahl
menschen in dieser studie auch infiziert
um an dann sieht ist dann unterschied
zwischen placebo
was immer die die null kontrolle so ist
sozusagen ist und dem echten impfstoff
nun gibt es viele die sagen ich bin
überhaupt kein impfgegner ich vertraue
da der wissenschaft und ich lasse mich
auch schon seit jahren regelmäßig impfen
aber bei dieser sache wurde das so
schnell geht habe ich meine zweifel auch
gerade was langzeitfolgen oder
langzeitschäden dieser impfung angeht
und möchte mich eigentlich nicht impfen
lassen oder erstmal nicht impfen lassen
was sagen sie denen ich kann das schon
nachvollziehen dass man sagt ich möchte
jetzt aber erstmal abwarten das sind ja
jetzt daten letztendlich die wir haben
die sagen bis sieben tage nach der
zweiten impfung ist man vor einer
infektion geschützt das sagt noch nicht
wie lange hält der schutz denn an
das sagt auch noch milch wie sieht denn
die der imf erfolg nach einem jahr oder
nach zwei jahren aus aber die studien
die laufen weiter und so hat man das
vereinbarte man hat so vereinbart dass
man eine zwischenanalyse macht das ist
das was jetzt passiert und dann
beobachtet man das weiter man schaut
also jetzt wie sieht es nach 14 tagen
aus wie sieht es in untergruppen aus als
er in jüngeren personen 12 bis 15
jährige wunder geimpft in älteren
personen funktioniert es da genauso gut
und es wird eine folgestudie geben wo
man wirklich sich dann auch den effekt
für zwei jahre an schauten einfach zu
wissen wie lange hält den tatsächlich
die impf antwort an
damit wäre frage 2 von david conen aus
wiesbaden schon beantwortet der nämlich
per e-mail sich an uns gewandt hat und
zum einen gefragt hat was für studien
müssen noch stattfinden damit der
impfstoff zu leiten zugelassen werden
kann
vielleicht können sie darauf gerne
trotzdem noch mal eingehen und die
zweite frage ist was kann mit der
aussage 90 prozentige wirksamkeit
gemeint sein
also wie gesagt diese studien müssen
weitergehen das ist ein erstes
zwischenergebnis was man hat das ist
sicherlich noch kein endergebnis
man muss natürlich jetzt auch nicht nur
die bewertung der der firma und das ja
die haben so ein ein unabhängiges
komitee das muss man bei jeder studie
einrichten was die wirksamkeit und auch
die sicherheit eines medikaments oder
einer impfung oder was immer man testet
bewertet das reicht aber nicht sondern
diese daten müssen jetzt eingereicht
werden bei den regulatorischen behörden
und die prüfen das ganze sehr gründlich
und unabhängig nochmal nach deswegen
wird auch diese zulassung ganz sicher
noch ein bisschen dauern
auch wenn man schon vorab unterlagen
eingereicht hat und das sind also einem
rollenden verfahren den regulatorischen
behörden gibt müssen jetzt trotzdem eine
unabhängige endprüfung das ganze nochmal
machen
das ist wichtig weil wir auch wirklich
sehr sehr sicher sein wollen dass dass
der impfstoff wirklich auch sicher ist
und auch die ganzen effizienz daten
stimmen
was heißt jetzt die effizienz daten was
heißt diese 90-prozentige effizienz das
klingt natürlich erstmal super toll aber
was man hier jetzt weiß ist dass man
wenn ich das aus der presserechtlich
entnommen habe 94 infektionen hatte
und wenn man dann sagen will man hat
eine 90-prozentige wirksamkeit muss es
also sein dass über 80 infektionen in
der kontrollgruppe die also placebo
sprich einfach kochsalz oder wasser
gespritzt bekommen hat und eben nur
wenige infektionen weniger als zehn
prozent demnach dann im in der an echten
gruppe also das dürften wenn man wenn
man jetzt wieder von den 90 auf 94
ausgehen ja maximal dann neun teilnehmer
sein dann könnte man von einer
90-prozentigen unterschied sprechen aber
die gruppe ist natürlich auch noch klein
das muss man auch ganz ehrlich sagen man
muss jetzt auf jeden fall erweitern das
steht so im studienprotokoll bis dann
164 infektionen gemessen sind und dann
schauen wie verteilt sich das auf die
beiden also auf den rechten arm und auf
den placebo arm und dann muss man gucken
ob sich diese hohe zahl der wirksamkeit
dann auch wirklich halten
lässt aber vielversprechend ist das
natürlich erst mal schon
sie haben gerade das stichwort
sicherheit genannt
es gibt ja nicht nur eine deutsche firma
und nicht nur mehrere deutsche firmen
die an diesem impfstoff arbeiten sondern
das ist ja ein weltweites rennen was
vergleichbar mit dem flug zum mond
stattfindet jeder will der erste sein
und viele firmen sind auch schon sehr
weit sind auch schon in dieser dritten
phase und es gibt zum beispiel den
russischen impfstoff stehe schon zum
teil
jetzt weiß ich nicht sie müssen mich
korrigieren schon zugelassen ist oder zu
mit dem zumindest auf jeden fall schon
auch geimpft wird und da fragt adam
schubert auf youtube was wenn ich den
russischen impfstoff möchte wird er auch
angeboten erstens dazu und zweitens was
sagen sie zur sicherheit dieses bereits
bestehenden den dieser bereits
bestehenden impfung also es gibt mehrere
firmen die solche rna impfstoffe
entwickeln eine firma die in usa ähnlich
weit ist es die firma moderne dies also
fast genauso weit wie jetzt bei entdeckt
und weiter in ihrer gemeinschaftsaktion
sind und dann gibt es andere impfstoffe
zum beispiel astrazeneca hat an den
impfstoff der vector basiert ist wie wir
sagen wollen sie die die ja das was für
das protein codiert durch ein vector
übertragen wird nicht durch eine rna die
sind auch schon sehr weit also wir haben
jetzt mehrere impfstoffe die sozusagen
in dieser phase 3 in der testung sind
gegenüber einem placebo
die anderen ergebnisse wissen wir noch
nicht der russische impfstoff das ist
auch sein vektorbasierte impfstoff der
ist aber nicht in einer phase 3 geprüft
worden
das heißt da hat man nur diese wenigen
hundert teilnehmer aus der phase 2
gehabt und dann haben die russen gesagt
na wunderbar funktioniert doch den
wänden wir gleich an
das mag auch sein dass der funktioniert
aber diese testung in einer großen
anzahl von probanden wo man dann
wirklich auch noch mal die sicherheit
bei vielen tausend menschen überprüft
und auch die wirksamkeit überprüft die
fehlt einfach
und diese saubere dokumentation des
ganzen
das ist das was die internationale
gemeinschaft dann einfach sehr
kritisiert hat an dem russischen
vorgehen
das heißt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
an diesen russischen impfstoff zu kommen
ist außer wenn man in russland lebt
nicht nicht denkbar
nein also bei uns wird dann ein
impfstoff der nicht das konsequente und
gesamte zulassungsverfahren am wirklich
durchlaufen hat der wird bei uns nicht
zugelassen und auch ein usa nicht
zugelassen und auch in ländern wie japan
oder so nicht zugelassen und es gibt dem
länder die nicht ganz so strikt mit
diesen vorschriften umgehen
ja das bei uns würde auf jeden fall
nicht verfügbar sein mit ohne dass man
diese kompletten daten letztendlich hat
wenn dann bei uns ein impfstoff
verfügbar ist dann ist die frage wer
wird denn dann zuerst geimpft und auch
da war heute ein wichtiger tag denn
wissenschaftler und ethiker haben ihre
empfehlungen vorgelegt und auch
gesundheitsminister sparen hat im
kanzleramt seine nationale impfstrategie
vorgestellt das schauen wir uns an die
hallen 25 und 26 der messe berlin
könnten ein so genanntes im zentrum
werden eines von rund 60 bundesweit die
umrüstung vom notfall krankenhaus das
cockpit 19 behandeln soll zum
impfzentrum das cockpit 19 verhindern
soll wäre eine frage von tagen das
impfen eine frage von monaten wenn nicht
jahren die wissenschaft schlägt vor
zuerst die variablen die besonders
gefährdeten gruppen zu impfen dann
medizinisches und pflegepersonal und
dann menschen mit für das gemeinwesen
besonders relevanten funktionen
mitarbeiter gesundheitsämter polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden feuerwehr
lehrerinnen und lehrer erzieherinnen und
erzieher so weit in ihrer impfstrategie
volk die bundesregierung dem vorschlag
nach berufsgruppen zu priorisieren ein
webbasiertes daten portal soll alter
geschlecht und wohnort der geimpften
erfassen aber nicht die namen auf jeden
fall soll die impfung freiwillig und
kostenlos sein
die mitteilung der firma bayern keck
dass ihr impfstoff zu 90 prozent wirksam
sei
elektrisiert das politische berlin das
war ja bis hierhin unsicher ob es
überhaupt einen impfstoff geben kann
der tatsächlich wirkt der tatsächliche
infektionsgeschehen reduzierten
infektionen vermeiden hilft und danach
sieht es stand heute aus und das ist
ermutigend mit den ersten impfungen
rechnet die bundesregierung bereits im
ersten quartal des nächsten jahres bis
die krankheit im griff ist müssten sich
wohl 70 prozent der bevölkerung impfen
lassen
tja da fragt titan tom auf youtube dazu
ist es realistisch dass im nächsten jahr
jeder in deutschland zugriff auf den
impfstoff hat ich befürchte nein denn
man muss ganz ehrlich sein wir haben 80
millionen menschen selbst wenn wir nur
die risikogruppen impfen würden das sind
dann etwa 24 millionen menschen das ist
natürlich nichts was man in ein paar
tagen mal schnell macht also wenn man
das innerhalb eines jahres verteilt
machen will dann sind das zwei millionen
menschen pro monat er das ist immer noch
eine riesen logistische leistung wenn
man das hinbekommen will also wirklich
jeden da innerhalb von einem jahr durch
zu impfen
das halte ich für sehr schwierig
vermutlich so nicht funktionieren
das heißt die anlass und von charlie
woodstock über youtube 60 bis 70 müssen
geimpft sein um eine herdenimmunität zu
erreichen
wie lange wird es dauern bis es erreicht
ist das wird eine ganze weile dauern
das wird schon ein bisschen dauern dazu
kommt aber natürlich es gibt jetzt auch
schon menschen die das die die infektion
durchgemacht haben im moment ja ich
würde mal schätzen so vielleicht etwa
zwei prozent der bevölkerung
jetzt im winter kommen da sicherlich
noch einige dazu und wenn man dann
anfangen kann vor allem auch die
risikogruppen zu impfen
das ist ja das wichtige dass man die
erstmal schützt eben ein risiko haben
schwer krank zu werden dann ist glaube
ich schon mal erheblich viel gewonnen
aber dass wir jetzt alle sofort ende
nächsten jahres immun sind
das
glaub ich noch nicht ganz weil sie die
risikopatienten gerade ansprechen
jenny ehrlich fragt auf facebook
verträgt sich der impfstoff mit
herzmedikamenten das ist natürlich schon
eine sehr spezielle medizinische frage
aber natürlich eine die gerade
risikopatienten betreffen würde können
sie darauf antworten und vielleicht ich
weiß nicht ob irgendjemand ein glas
wasser für sie hat es tut mir furchtbar
leid
ich hoffe sie halten noch ein paar
minuten durch das können wir gerne
irgendwie eine kleine pause machen und
sie trinken schlug wir haben zeit alles
gut ich glaube dazu gibt es noch keine
daten in ehrlich gesagt es gibt keinen
hinweis dass der impfstoff irgendwie mit
medikamenten interferieren würde denn
der wird ja nicht eingenommen und er
muss ja nicht verstoffwechselt werden im
körper wie jetzt tabletten so dass man
eine direkte interferenz miteinander
befürchten müsste es sind bei diesen
44.000 menschen die jetzt geimpft worden
davon ein teil natürlich mit placebo ein
teil mit dem echten impfstoff hat man
schon versucht möglichst verschiedene
gruppen einzubeziehen und auch patienten
mit vorerkrankungen mit vor infektionen
einzubeziehen sodass man wie eine
gewisse daten hat ob jetzt zum beispiel
eine vor bestehende infektionen nehmen
sie an jemand es hiv positiv am zb
solche patienten oder solche probanden
hat man einbezogen
und natürlich werden da auch menschen
dabei seien die blutdruckmedikamente
nehmen oder herzmedikamente nehmen dass
es ja doch eine häufige medikation die
genommen wird aber wenn man das ganz
spezifische untersuchen will dann muss
man jetzt einfach nach der zulassung
dann abwarten und ganz gezielt nochmal
beobachtungen machen aber rein von der
logik her würde ich eigentlich nicht
denken dass der impfstoff mit
irgendeinem medikament jetzt
interagieren kann
viele denken auch an nebenwirkungen
abgesehen von möglichen
interaktionen mit anderen medikamenten
silvia fragt auf facebook welche
nebenwirkungen sind zu erwarten
also nebenwirkungen die man erwarten
muss ist alles was man spürt an
stimulation des immunsystems das weiß
jeder von einer impfung was man häufig
spürt ist sand ziehen an der stelle wo
man geimpft wurde
warum weil dort immunzellen einwandern
das spürt man natürlich so ein bisschen
wie wenn man sich verletzt hat oder so
auch was man auch erwarten kann ist dass
man die generelle stimulation der
anregung des immunsystems spürt dabei
kann es mal so ein bisschen erhöhten
körpertemperaturen kommen kopfschmerzen
vielleicht auch gliederschmerzen zu
einer abgeschlagenheit für ein zwei tage
sowas kann man durchaus als
nebenwirkungen oder reaktionen auf eine
impfung erwarten das sieht man auch bei
vielen anderen impfungen wenn ich das
richtig
haben sie die frage von bernd pohl auf
facebook schon mit beantwortet werden
menschen mit einer immunschwäche auch
mit dem impfstoff geimpft das haben sie
gerade angesprochen zb mit der hiv
infektion richtig ganz genau das hat man
absichtlich gemacht dass man auch
menschen mit einer virushepatitis oder
einer hiv-infektion eingeschlossen hat
weil man einfach wissen wollte hat der
der impfstoff einen effekt auf die
infektion dass es mit untersucht worden
daten dazu kenne ich mich da muss man
die publikation dann abwarten wo man
sich ja auch noch drauf schauen muss ist
menschen die autoimmunerkrankungen haben
ist da schon genügend und es sind da
schon genügend daten da um zu sagen der
impfstoff ist auch in dieser gruppe
genauso sicher da muss man jetzt dann
wirklich die detailanalysen und
letztendlich dann die publikation der
daten abwarten
das kann man so nicht beantworten nun
kommt diese meldung heute an
einem tag der schlechten nachrichten
gebracht hat die zahl der neuinfektionen
liegt bei etwa 13.000 das ist
verhältnismäßig niedrig im vergleich zu
den letzten tagen aber wir kennen das
montags und dienstags sind die zahlen
eher niedrig weil nicht alle
gesundheitsämter die daten an das lka
weiter übermitteln aber es gibt eine
andere zahl 3000 fünf menschen mit coop
19 werden derzeit auf intensivstationen
versorgt und das sind so viele wie noch
nie das sind mehr als auf dem bisherigen
höhepunkt im april
da waren es 2009 100 patienten nun gibt
es seit zwei wochen seit einer woche
sorry diesen teil lockdown und die
entwicklung schlagen sich noch nicht
nieder in den zahlen die im moment
vorliegen
wie wichtig ist es dass es bald einen
impfstoff gibt wenn sie sich diese
entwicklung anschauen
ich glaube es noch ein bisschen zu früh
um zu sagen der teil noch dann kann sich
schon niederschlagen auf die zahlen wir
wissen ja dass das immer sieben bis zehn
tage dauert bis man wirklich dann auch
ein effekt sieht also ich denke mal im
laufe dieser woche sollte man den ersten
effekt dann wirklich sehen
bis man einen effekt sieht auf die
belegung der intensivstationen und das
ist leider das traurige dabei sind
mindestens zwei bis drei wochen
denn es dauert einfach doch mindestens
zwei wochen bis jemand der sich
infiziert auch auf die intensivstation
kommt und zu den zahlen der intensiv
belegung muss man sagen jetzt ist
natürlich die infektion doch relativ
gleichmäßig über deutschland verteilt
das heißt wir haben zwar mehr patienten
leider auf den intensivstationen als wir
in der ersten welle hatten aber in der
ersten welle war das punktueller da
waren eben gewisse bereiche gerade hier
im süden im südlichen bayern und auch in
baden württemberg extrem betroffen und
der rest von deutschland war er weniger
betroffen
jetzt verteilt sich das ein bisschen
besser wir haben auch besser gelernt wie
man damit umgeht wir haben die ersten
medikamente in der hand so dass man mit
dieser zahl schon deutlich besser
umgehen kann als man das im ersten bälle
konnte wie lange wird es jetzt oder wann
wird uns da ein impfstoff dann abhilfe
schafft
ja das hängt natürlich davon ab wie
schnell gehen jetzt die zahlen wieder
runter wann wird der impfstoff
letztendlich wirklich dann zugelassen
sein das wird ja ziemlich sicher nicht
mehr in diesem jahr der fall sein
sondern irgendwann anfang nächsten
jahres der fall sein dann kann man dann
auch tatsächlich mit impfungen beginnen
also ich persönlich glaube nicht dass
die impfung noch einen signifikanten
effekt auf die welle hat die wir jetzt
im moment haben und die uns ja sicher
bis einschließlich februar vermutlich in
den märz hinein begleiten wird
ich würde gerne zwei fragen noch
unterbringen die eine ist es gibt immer
wieder das wort von der impfpflicht was
gerade bei corona leugnen verschwörungs
mäßig herumgeistert der
gesundheitsminister selbst hat es auch
heute noch mal gesagt es wird eine
freiwillige impfung seien es wird keine
verpflichtung geben sich impfen zu
lassen
es gibt menschen die glauben dass es so
eine art versteckte impfpflicht gibt
dass man zb einen nachweis vorlegen muss
dass man geimpft wurde um weiß ich nicht
irgendwelche leistungen zu bekommen oder
irgendwie in den kindergarten in die
schule zur arbeit gehen zu können
der frack mister day walker 1995 auf
youtube werden diejenigen die sich
impfen lassen irgendeine art von ich bin
geimpft karte oder so erhalten
also es gibt natürlich an impfpass in
dem sind alle impfungen eingetragen egal
ob ich mich jetzt gegen masern gegen
tetanus oder gegen influenza impfen
lassen und da wird sicherlich auch die
korona virus impfen eingetragen werden
eine impfpflicht halte ich ehrlich
gesagt für ausgeschlossen denn wir
werden erstmal gar nicht genügend
impfstoff haben um überhaupt die schnell
versorgen zu können die sich gerne
impfen lassen möchten
insofern es wird erstmal der riesen
logistische herausforderung sein das
heißt ich denke eine impfpflicht kann
ich mir persönlich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen und ich glaube das war auch
politisch überhaupt nie in der
diskussion gerade für solche so ein
impfstoff das ist ja ähnlich wie beim
influenza impfstoff auch dass meine
empfehlung hat für bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen aber natürlich kein
pflicht dann möchte ich gerne die letzte
frage stellen sich viele user offenbar
gestellt haben nämlich die ob sie sich
selbst auch impfen lassen werden also
ich habe mich jetzt gerade gegen den
fans helfen lassen das tue ich jedes
jahr und ich werde mich sicherlich auch
gegen kuwait 19 impfen lassen gar keine
frage vielen dank frau professor trotz
dafür das gespräch nach münchen
dankeschön fürs zuschauen
sie haben nicht so geschaut sie haben
mitgemacht aber unsere zuschauer und
user haben auch mitgemacht und auch
zuschauer zugeschaut von daher vielen
dank an alle und an alle einen
wunderschönen abend tschüss